let's get to a single best chart here's
Brendan Greeley deposits by American
non-financial companies the past 1
trillion dollars for the first time last
year they are still at that level now
mattress stuffing is the subject of
today's single best chart Tom what we're
looking at there is deposits as a
percentage of GDP it is at five point
seven percent right now that is its
highest level since at the time of JFK
1963 that is amazing you know and we
have Bob cinch with us here right now on
the desk from Amherst pierpoint pierpont
excuse me what does that say to you good
is what why is there not a better use of
cash right now well it's certainly not
keeping it on deposit for the high
interest rates we know that part right
again I think this gets back to the fact
that global growth is is not robust the
investment opportunities aren't there
particularly in the manufacturing
sectors were often you would build up
large use large amounts of capital to to
build facilities you know as you guys
have been mentioning a lot of these
technology companies very few employees
you don't need big facilities to produce
information and produce technology so
you know this is an adjustment process
and it's it's not the kind of economy
we've been used to for the last 50 years
well is this build up in deposits in the
part of consumer is a sort of fear that
you know things aren't gonna get better
anytime soon or is it just that they
don't know what to do with this cash I
think it's a they don't know what to do
with the cash you know there's been
concerns all along companies don't have
a place to really invest very
aggressively I think individuals are
feeling the same way and if you're going
to get paid very little you may as well
have it on deposit and at least have the
insurance could we see these savings at
any point bleed into wage increases you
know I think there are signs that waging
wages are beginning to increase the
average hourly earnings numbers that we
just got last week that's probably the
least reliable wage series we have
because its a mix of who's working and
what their salaries are I think in
general we're starting to see signs that
wages are picking up we certainly have a
lot of anecdotal evidence to that effect
so I think we're starting to see that
the labor market is tightening up and
that gets back to your potential growth
discussion earlier this economy has been
growing at 2.32 points
four percent and we're tightening the
labor market the unemployment rates
coming down that's that's the clearest
evidence we have that potential growth
is less than 2% listen I've been running
about that with john herman of
mitsubishi and Michael Feroli and
champion Morgan among others do you buy
the idea that the Fed is behind and that
the entire terminal rate that we're
heading towards is a lower yield lower
interest rate economy well I think the
Fed is behind in the sense that they've
been very slow to adjust to this to this
expectation that potential growth is
probably less than 2% you know they
still keep talking about 3% yeah your
next year yeah bit like the Chicago Cubs
but you know we're at a point now where
I think they're beginning to realize the
potential growth is lower I think
they're taking that into their set of
expectations and and lower potential
growth probably does mean that the
equilibrium rate is lower I just got to
give credit where credit is due that
chart came from pavilion global we've
got a great quote from the people who
pulled it together it seems that
companies have no idea what to do with
their cash yes it does seem so funny